hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
contrary to reports on CNN I am NOT
juror b37 i am dave rubin we've got two
great comedians with us this week kira
soltanovich and jimmy dore both repeat
guests on the reuben report and it's not
easy it's not easy to do that never know
what you're gonna say to do time repeat
guests that's right all right we got a
lot to talk about so let's roll Twitter
I love Twitter full disclosure addicted
to twitter never want to say anything
bad about Twitter but I'm a little a
little displeased with the Twitter
people this week because there is a
lawsuit in France you know France has
strict hate speech laws you can't deny
the Holocaust they don't want people
putting up pure hate speech anti-semitic
self anti-muslim stuff blah blah blah
and now the French government is
cooperating with Twitter or Twitter's
cooperating with the French government i
should say to prosecute persecute people
who are putting up hate speech on
twitter that was the oddest most
roundabout logic intro I've ever given
to a segment guys we're all comedians we
love free speech not everyone oughtta be
country has it the way we have it here
in America but is this bad news that
Twitter would cooperate with a
government to stop people from saying
what they want to say in the social
media sphere Kiera go is it cuz I'm a
Jew you're starting to eat you yeah if
you can't be anti-semitic on Twitter
then what is the point yeah dude I mean
it's the last beer where is the last
place where it's like ad Jews you cheap
bastards right it's the last place to do
that in 140 characters or less yeah I am
look I there are a lot of complaints i
have about the french and if they want
to lock down those anti-semites then
that's their business I feel like it's
we should as cuz twitter is based out of
here california i feel like we almost
have responsibilities right right
Silicon Valley that's where I grew up in
San Francisco if that's what the
government is saying this will what we
hold true in our government I feel like
maybe they should uphold that I don't
know I just right then again I also feel
like a Jew joke is pretty funny usual
generally but yet twitter did open
offices in France recently so they do
have other legal obligations now it's
not just that Twitter's here Jimmy
comedian we all free speech we always
back it but Kira's Kira's down with the
what the French are doing I didn't know
any of this stuff about Frances and so
funny when you started talking about
this ensures I'm like oh I just read a
story about this I'm sorry could you
said I said to you that was me yesterday
sending you the email on that yeah yeah
he just got to get around for the record
one camera here for the record jimmy
strolled in 10 seconds ago with a banana
and a traveling bag like literally like
a comedian like you were gonna throw a
banana peel and then where's your rubber
chicken dude there's no coffee today for
some and there's no coffee anyway i just
say it seems like you know France is uh
I didn't know that you can police speech
like that like you can you can't be mean
to someone or you can't be disparaging
right but that's just funny to me and I
think it's because the other over
compensating obviously the French
because you get because right and yeah
for the end they stink the penises they
don't put the order on them yes and
they're always smoking and they're
depressed yes because they sent the Jews
to even work in concentration chemical
or you know I sent him away they made a
deal with Hitler so they've had that
guilty conscience now ever since then so
but we don't have that here in America
right in fact we should we don't have
one you can say whatever you want on
Twitter about anybody right right
american indians african-americans as a
matter particularly if you're alec
baldwin's those i can't take them yeah i
am all for you know free speech
obviously for our country but i do feel
like if the people of France then all of
a sudden will go to Twitter to jump on
the jube and wet let's more of a train
but you know what I mean like if they
jump on it then I don't know I'm torn by
this because as a comic I do believe in
free speech right but you should say
that I really am because it so let's go
the opposite way because we do have free
speech right right what if there was
some social network out of I don't know
the Middle East somewhere that we all
jumped on we were like I love
it's so great to put pictures on that
but then they start you know I ticky
ticky look at my picture okay could
happen it could happen but you're not
really you're not you don't think this
is a good thing that you can't say what
you want publicly I think no for us yeah
cuz we do in our country even if Rick
France it's bad right well no we have we
have the First Amendment here I mean
that's an American thing everyone think
so everybody has the first minute but
it's actually just an American thing
that was our ego in right isn't havenae
yeah hey that's right but I think you're
onto something about you know the Arab
Spring look if the government were
working with Twitter to stop the tweets
coming out of Tahrir Square then they
probably wouldn't have had the
revolution last year or the revolution
last week yeah so is that the real
danger that sure it may seem okay at
first that you you know you quiet up
some people that are spewing hate but
then ultimately you get people I don't
think you know I think it's like a
bubble you know or like balloon you
squeeze it here it could go and expands
there you can't it's just like
pornography you know the more you try to
push it down the darker it gets and the
more pervasive so this is I understand
like again I understand they're guilty
conscience I was shocked the Twitter
rolled over like this for them they
rolled over pretty easily they could
have fought back harder and it makes me
nervous now you know like I have friends
who just dropped their Facebook accounts
because they're sick and tired I'm sick
and tired of it you go to a Huffington
Post or any website and all of a sudden
they know who you are and what you've
been doing and here's what you're
reading and here's an ad because you
were looking for that thing on amazon
yesterday and I'm like what is going on
yeah so wait actually let's take a look
at some some stats some Twitter stats
who they're working with and then we can
talk about why so in terms of censorship
in the second half of 2012 Twitter
received over a thousand requests from
government agencies in the US and abroad
it complied to varying degrees
sixty-nine percent of the time with
respect to requests from American
authorities that's that's pretty high
thirty-three percent from the Dutch and
never in cases of countries like India
Israel or turkey but seventy percent of
the time they're doing stuff that the
u.s. government wants now we are in the
US here does that make you a little
nervous we don't know what they're doing
oh cool we don't know what the
government's doing makes me
yes I don't like that i don't like that
it's ridiculous yes I don't like social
networks can you know working with the
government stop if the government if you
do you make is that make you
uncomfortable uncomfortable guys see how
much I tweet I put a ton of stuff out
there but the thing is with Twitter it's
a thank you thank you very much uh-uh
but Twitter the thing is with twitter it
is all public it's not like what you're
saying with facebook where like if you
go to huffington post and suddenly it
magically appears on your facebook
twitter we all know that everything we
say is is that we're putting it out so
the issue here is about anonymity right
because if you were saying something
particularly hateful anonymously you
know mean it's not like you know what
you put something out it has your name
attached to it versus if you were trying
to fight the government and nicely right
you know well i have a couple of those
pages yeah yeah yeah you know what I've
knows about that these were anonymity
Polly word it and not clandestinely yeah
tweeting anti-semitic stuff in France
yes and so Twitter said i'll let you
know who these guys are right and it's
not just anti symmetric sockets
anti-muslim stuff it's just it's pure
hate so what could they be but you know
the thing is we don't know what those
things were that the government
requested from Twitter what Twitter gave
them what though we like you said it is
public so what the are they
requesting right right it's a little
it's a little bizarre anyway twitter i
just want to say to you personally i'd
still love you and you know we'll keep
doing this and you gotta do what you